how to save a baby bird it is not
uncommon to find the baby bird on the
ground if it has feathers it is likely a
nestling some nestlings explore the
ground before learning to fly the mother
will bring food when there is no danger
in these cases it's best to leave the
birds alone take any pets or children
inside and watch from a distance for
about an hour if the mother bird visits
everything is ok if the baby bird has no
feathers or just the beginning of
feathers you can put it back in its nest
if you don't see a nest you can make one
by lining a little box or plastic tub
with shredded paper towel or tissue
don't use cotton products as these can
tangle put the nest in a shady spot up
in a tree or bush without endangering
yourself in the process
fortunately it is not true that baby
birds will be rejected if touched by
humans again watch from afar for about
an hour if the mother visits your work
is done if you know the bird is injured
or that the mother has died it's best to
call your local animal rescue center
they will know what to do if you have
touched the baby bird make sure to
thoroughly wash your hands afterward for
more animal rescue tips visit wild son
rescue center
[Music]